on va mettre le soir entre parenthèses
pendant quelques instants pour se
pencher sur la question du logement
social cécile duflot ministre du
logement a fait des propositions pour
débloquer des terrains appartenant à
l'état quel impact dans l'agglomération
de saint quentin
maxime lemaire pour atteindre l'objectif
de 150 mille nouveaux logements sociaux
par an fixé par françois hollande
pendant sa campagne la ministre cécile
duflot a proposé la semaine dernière un
renforcement de la loi sru
la loi de solidarité et de
renouvellement urbain jusqu'à présent en
ile-de-france les communes de plus de
1500 habitants devait avoir en moins 20%
de logements sociaux
la ministre souhaite voir ce chiffre
augmenter de 5 points
où en sont les communes sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
petit tour d'horizon en chiffres la
verrière arrive en tête des sept
communes suivie de près par trappe et
magny les hameaux manyu deux projets
immobiliers comportant des logements
sociaux sont prévus à l'est des
capucines et rue gabriel-péri lui en
cours se place en quatrième position
230 nouveaux logements sociaux devraient
sortir de terre prochainement a dit le
roi sud au niveau de la ferme de
châteauneuf et sur l'emplacement de
l'ancienne école paul langevin
ils seront mélangés avec des habitats
classique afin de favoriser la mixité
sociale
la commune de guyancourt a d'ailleurs
indiqué dans son pays et lui que tout
projet de construction de 60 logements
ou plus doit comporter 50 % de logements
sociaux et l'encours et montigny le
bretonneux sont au coude à coude voisins
le bretonneux quant à elle arrive bonne
dernière c'est la seule commune à ne pas
respecter les 20% de logements sociaux
obligatoires
les sanctions encourues jusqu'à l'or
pourrait être multiplié par 5 avec la
nouvelle loi qui sera est une
l'assemblée nationale à partir du 24
septembre